have you ever wondered what an 80's
television advert for Xavier's school
for gifted youngsters would look like no
or here it is anyway I'm Simon and this
is your mutant news update while the
build-up to the release of x-men
apocalypse has featured the expected
range of trailers and TV spots there
have also been a number of inventive
retro promos and the latest takes the
form of an 80 style recruitment
infomercial in a recent interview with
den of geek director Bryan Singer spoke
about the film's 80 setting this one is
set when I was in high school this was
when I discovered my love for movies and
the arcade video games so I kind of
brought a sense of color to the film
that I was more cautious about you know
I always liked the x-men films to be
very much grounded in reality but here i
could get closer to the comic book I
felt the imagery from the comic book in
certain characters and their costumes
just the overall design and the music of
course so yeah it was just a really nice
era to play with Xmen apocalypse stars
James McAvoy Michael Fassbender Jennifer
Lawrence or sky Zack nicholas hoult and
rose byrne it opens on May 27th are you
excited for the new x-men let me know in
the comments or come find me on twitter
i'm at the jagan or thanks for watching
and for your entertainment news keep it
gamespot
you